-Lionel Naccache, bonjour.
-Bonjour, Mazarine Pingeot.
-Vous êtes chercheur
en neuroscience cognitive.
On s'intéresse à la question
du vivant.
Cette question,
aujourd'hui centrale
notamment en raison
de la crise écologique
et du développement
de l'écologie politique,
pose le problème
de notre rapport au monde.
Les philosophies du vivant
et la biologie
semblent préférer
une vision continuiste
et relationnelle du vivant.
Nous appartenons au grand tout,
nous n'en sommes
qu'un chaînon,
tout est interconnecté,
tout est en tout.
C'est l'hypothèse Gaïa,
je simplifie.
Mais ça n'est pas votre position.
Comment faire partie du monde
sans nécessairement s'y fondre ?
-C'est la question qui m'a inspiré
dans ce nouveau livre,
celle du rapport... Ce lien
au monde. On fait partie du monde
mais comment penser ce lien,
notre appartenance ?
Il m'a semblé qu'on peut utiliser
cette paire de lunettes
entre deux principes en tension,
celui de la continuité,
et pour plein de raisons,
je crois qu'intuitivement,
on a des raisons d'aimer
cette continuité
et de penser que les choses
sont continues
dans le monde et même en nous.
Mais en opposition ou en apposition
à ce principe,
il y a celui
que j'ai appelé la discrétion,
c'est pas son vrai nom.
On pourrait parler
de discontinuité,
en fait.
C'est un concept
presque mathématique.
C'est le discret
et le continu.
Il m'a semblé,
pour des raisons
qui ont à voir
avec mon activité de chercheur,
que cette paire de lunettes
pouvait nous aider,
en l'utilisant,
à repenser de la manière
"la plus adéquate possible"
la meilleure façon,
ou en tout cas
une des façons de penser
ce lien au monde.
On voit les écueils.
D'un côté, si on imagine
que les choses sont
en discontinuité,
on voit apparaître l'écueil
d'une sorte
d'égoïsme radical.
On est totalement séparé,
rien ne nous unit,
rien ne nous relie.
A l'inverse,
l'idée d'une fusion totale
me semble tout autant
illusoire,
voire même dangereuse.
Dangereuse par les effets
de danger
où on pense être dans une sorte
de position généreuse,
mais qui était très narcissique.
Ca peut paraître un peu compliqué
résumé comme ça,
mais c'est cette paire de lunettes,
continu et discret...
En français,
on parle de discontinuité
mais si on fait attention
au mot, la discontinuité,
ça veut dire qu'on va définir
le discret en négatif,
qui n'est pas de la continuité.
On peut aussi positivement
le définir,
d'où cet usage néologique
de la discrétion,
non pas dans son sens psychologique
mais dans l'idée
de quelque chose
qui n'est pas en continuité.
-Peut-être qu'on verra
les implications
politiques, sociologiques,
justement,
de cette préférence
pour le continu.
Déjà, revenons aux assises
de cette préférence erronée
pour le continu, et la façon
dont fonctionne notre conscience.
-Cette réflexion
s'est enracinée.
Je m'intéresse à la subjectivité
avec le regard d'un chercheur
en neuroscience.
Comment est-ce qu'on perçoit
nous-mêmes ?
Un des ingrédients principaux,
c'est une sorte
de cinéma intérieur.
Au cinéma, en fait,
le principe un peu magique
du cinéma,
quand vous êtes
dans un fauteuil,
c'est que vous allez percevoir
un film qui a l'air continu.
On a l'impression de voir
le film continu.
Un personnage qui se déplace,
un véhicule...
En réalité,
ce qu'on sait tous,
le truc magique au cinéma,
c'est que sur l'écran,
on ne vous projette pas
un film continu
mais on envoie une série discrète
d'images fixes,
des images discrètes,
le fameux 24 images seconde,
mais on ne perçoit pas
la suite stroboscopique des images,
mais du continu.
Au cinéma, on vous envoie
du discret,
et nous moulinons ça en continu,
le film que nous percevons.
Le film que nous percevons,
ce n'est pas abusif de dire
que personne ne nous l'a montré.
Il s'est construit en nous
avec une sorte de machine
à combler les trous
qui manquent.
Entre deux images
qui se succèdent,
notre cerveau,
si on veut l'appeler comme ça,
sans être finaliste,
produit, en fait,
ce qui n'a pas été donné,
invente cette continuité.
Là où cette histoire
de cinéma intérieur
devient fantastique,
c'est que cette histoire
de mouliner du discret
en du continu, ça existe aussi
dans la vie réelle.
Lorsque nous nous voyons
directement,
d'une certaine manière,
mon cerveau et le vôtre
font des captures
à peu près à 10 images secondes,
tout ça avec des guillemets
parce que nos pensées sont
plus complexes qu'une image,
mais font des saisies discrètes
et inventent le continu.
Notre perception du mouvement
est un film subjectif.
-Elle invente
ou est-ce que notre conscience
synthétise,
comme le dirait Kant ?
-C'est une fonction
de création
de quelque chose
qui n'est pas là.
Une façon...
On peut jouer avec les références
cinématographiques.
Dans "Matrix", je ne sais pas
si vous vous souvenez,
mais le personnage initié
à cette sorte de mythe
de caverne contemporaine,
Néo, quand il découvre
qu'il vit dans la matrice,
il y a des détails,
des "déjà vécus".
C'est la scène d'un petit chat.
Quand vous voyez
deux fois le même chat,
c'est un bug dans la matrice.
Il y a l'équivalent au cinéma.
Au cinéma,
il y a l'illusion de la roue
qui tourne
à l'envers.
Vous avez vu dans un film
des diligences,
des voitures, des vélos,
le véhicule va dans un sens
et les roues tournent
dans l'autre sens.
Ce phénomène-là, au cinéma,
on l'explique
parce qu'il dépend de la vitesse
de la roue
et de l'échantillonnage
de la caméra.
S'il y a deux positions
qui suivent le mouvement,
notre cerveau invente
le film continu,
mais si la roue va trop vite,
et que l'image suivante donne
un mouvement
de précession apparente,
quand la roue fait
plus d'un demi-tour,
votre machine à inventer
le mouvement
invente la direction inverse.
Là où ça devient intéressant,
c'est qu'en dehors du cinéma,
sur le périph' en voiture,
si vous êtes en voiture,
vous verrez qu'on voit aussi
des roues qui tournent à l'envers.
Cette fois-ci,
pas parce qu'on nous a montré
des images fixes,
mais parce que nous fonctionnons
comme ça.
C'est une création,
pas une synthèse.
On n'invente
ce qu'on n'a pas vu,
d'une manière plus générale
que l'exemple que j'ai donné.
-C'est assez fascinant,
mais du coup,
ça expliquerait la propension
à croire le monde continu.
-Oui, je crois
qu'on a...
Tout ça, on peut ensuite...
En biologie, en neuroscience,
il y a parfois
une recherche du sens.
Pourquoi notre machinerie biologique
a évolué ainsi ?
On peut imaginer plein de raisons
en évolution darwinienne,
en se disant par exemple
que c'est plus simple
que notre cerveau
ne traite qu'une portion limitée
de la réalité.
S'il devait traiter
en temps réel tout ça,
c'est impossible,
il serait en retard sur le réel.
Première réponse. Deuxième réponse,
plus intéressante,
c'est que le fait
que nous produisions
quelque chose
que nous n'avons pas perçu,
ça veut dire
que notre esprit n'est pas là
pour recevoir
ou pour synthétiser,
mais pour produire,
pour être en avance sur la réalité,
pour pouvoir faire advenir
des choses
qui n'existent pas encore,
pour le meilleur ou pour le pire.
On peut imaginer pourquoi
nos systèmes biologiques
ont évolué comme ça
mais là où ça devient fascinant,
c'est qu'effectivement,
le fait de savoir
que nous fonctionnons comme ça
nous permet d'éclairer
cette propension
à imaginer
les choses continues.
Dans plein d'éléments,
on imagine que l'espace est continu
au sens mathématique.
Si vous discutez
avec des physiciens,
vous verrez
que c'est un débat immémorial
mais très contemporain.
Est-ce que la matière,
est-ce que l'espace
est discret ou continu ?
On l'intuitionne comme continu,
et le temps aussi.
Notre introspection du temps est
souvent du temps continu,
non seulement le temps du monde
mais aussi notre temps.
Lorsqu'on pense à celui ou celle
qu'on a été,
il y a 1 an ou 30 ans,
on s'imagine souvent
dans une continuité de ça.
Je pense que d'un point de vue,
donc...
Caméra subjective de l'individu,
le continu domine.
Pour plein de raisons,
on rend en continu des choses
qui ne le sont pas
ou dont nous n'avons pas
des connaissances continues.
On produit du continu et je pense
que c'est un des facteurs,
un des moteurs qui,
lorsque l'on pense la question
du lien au reste du monde
que nous,
les autres humains,
le monde non-humain, la nature,
l'univers, on a peut-être
cette propension,
guidée par cette intuition
immémoriale
de mouliner du discret
en du continu,
d'imaginer que notre lien
est continu.
Là où c'est intéressant,
c'est qu'on a des raisons de penser
que c'est pas continu.
Je pense que ça ne l'est pas.
On peut montrer
que ce principe de discrétion
est au coeur du fonctionnement
de notre esprit, de notre cerveau,
et le savoir peut nous aider
à repenser ces questions.
-Ca questionne la place
du sujet.
-Exactement.
-Et d'ailleurs,
pour interroger le sujet,
vous convoquez deux philosophes,
un petit peu
pour polariser
deux grandes positions,
que sont Descartes et Spinoza.
-Ce livre,
ça m'a beaucoup amusé de l'écrire
comme ça.
Je l'ai écrit...
Il a la forme de "L'éthique"
de Spinoza,
c'est une liste de propositions,
d'axiomes,
pour lui donner
une structure discrète,
avec la discontinuité
du langage.
C'était un élément fondamental.
Ce sont des philosophes
de la modernité
qui paraissent assez anciens
mais qui sont au coeur
de cette question.
-Ils inaugurent la modernité.
-Ils l'inaugurent,
je pense qu'on est au coeur de ça.
Pourquoi ces deux ? D'un côté...
En tout cas,
c'est ma lecture de ces philosophes.
On a Descartes,
qui va vraiment poser le sujet
au sens de subjectivité,
qui se demande
à partir d'où on pense.
Il se rend compte
que croire pouvoir sortir de soi,
c'est illusoire.
Je suis dans ma subjectivité,
comment je fais pour essayer
de gérer cette question ?
Et tout commence par le sujet.
Ma compréhension du cogito,
du "je pense donc je suis",
c'est vraiment commencer par ça,
commencer
par ne jamais sortir.
Ou pour viser au-delà de soi,
ne pas oublier
qu'on pense à travers soi.
Avec comme leçon philosophique
l'idée que croire pouvoir sortir
de soi,
c'est pour moi une gageure,
et souvent
une sorte de piège
où on voit bien que l'écueil,
c'est de penser
être sorti de soi
alors qu'on n'en sort jamais
vraiment,
et donc pouvoir croire
accéder à ce continu
dans lequel on baignerait,
mais qui n'est que mon nombril
qui se projette sur le monde,
et en toute bonne conscience.
Et Spinoza en face,
parce que le fait de dire
"je sors de moi",
il y a une substance
et cette substance se décline
avec ses attributs,
et de dire que là,
le monde se pense comme une chose,
comme une substance infinie
dont nous faisons tous partie.
Descartes et Spinoza,
les deux sont au coeur du livre.
Ca penche plus vers Descartes...
(-Très bien.)
-...pour l'aspect discret
mais Spinoza n'est jamais
très loin.
-C'est bien de réhabiliter
Descartes par les temps qui courent.
-Vous avez raison.
C'est vrai.
Il y a aussi, évidemment,
des choses
qu'on peut questionner
mais en tout cas,
j'aime bien l'humilité,
pas en général, mais de Descartes.
J'aime cette idée de...
Quand vous réalisez
que tout ce que vous pensez
en tant qu'être conscient,
vous le pensez à partir de ce point
d'observation sur le monde
dont vous ne pouvez pas sortir,
j'aime cette figure.
-Ca a des implications
politiques.
Ca a des implications éthiques,
même.
Cette position
du sujet va vous amener
à repenser le rapport à l'autre
et le rapport au collectif.
-Oui, avec l'idée que le principe
qui se dégage...
L'éthique que j'essaye de dégager,
c'est une éthique
où on commence
par prendre conscience
de notre discrétion.
Je ne suis pas vous,
je ne suis pas le reste
de la nature,
je ne suis pas un fleuve.
La première étape est
une prise de conscience
de la discrétion individuelle.
Et là aussi, le curseur,
c'est l'individu,
la conscience individuelle,
avec l'idée que, dès lors que,
pour différentes raisons,
il y a des forces ou des tendances
qui veulent déplacer le curseur
au-delà du sujet,
dans des communautés, des groupes,
quelle que soit la cause
pour laquelle on veut le faire,
religieuse, politique...
Dès lors qu'on perd le sujet ou,
entre guillemets,
qu'on sacrifie le sujet,
dans cette éthique que je propose,
ça fonctionne pas.
On peut aussi déplacer le curseur
en infra-sujet.
Dans certaines formes
d'écologie radicale,
on peut dire qu'on est tous
constitués de matériaux biologiques.
Le sujet est une structure
éphémère,
avec tout son narcissisme
étriqué,
et on peut essayer de déplacer
le curseur en bas.
L'éthique que je propose
a un cap fixe, qui est le sujet.
C'est l'individu conscient.
A partir de là,
il y a deux temps.
Le premier est de reprendre
conscience,
lorsqu'on a une question
à se poser,
de cette discrétion du sujet.
Ensuite,
il y a un deuxième temps,
qu'on n'est pas obligé de faire,
qui est optionnel
et qui demande de l'engagement,
de la lucidité, et aussi,
j'aime bien le dire, du panache.
Sachant que je suis discret,
je vais oser le "comme si"
de continuité.
Je ne vais pas croire
que je suis en continuité
avec le monde, mais je vais
considérer que je suis
dans ce "comme si".
Non pas une simulation
du mensonge
mais de la volonté.
Je décide en toute connaissance
de cause.
Il y a un peu de ridicule,
c'est pas comme ça que nous sommes,
mais je vais faire comme ça.
Je m'engage dans ce "comme si"
pour penser
le lien avec le reste du monde.
Et au passage,
de manière tout à fait simple,
on se rend compte
que la meilleure façon
de penser le lien
à quelqu'un
ou à quelque chose
qui n'est pas vous,
c'est de commencer par prendre
conscience de la séparation.
Si on imagine être
dans un grand tout,
la notion de lien n'a plus
de sens.
Vous n'êtes plus en lien
avec vous-même.
La séparation est la condition
même première de valoriser
le lien.
Sinon,
il n'y a pas d'idée de lien.
C'est l'appareil
auquel j'aboutis,
et on peut l'utiliser pour
l'éclairer sur les questions
contemporaines,
sur les luttes progressistes,
la question de fin de vie.
-Sur la question de la fin de vie,
par exemple ?
-Sur la fin de vie, en fait,
il y a deux aspects.
Il y a un aspect que je traite
pas beaucoup dans ce livre
qui est l'aspect législatif.
Est-ce qu'on va vers une loi
qui changerait,
au-delà de la loi Léonetti...
Il y a une dimension législative
qui m'intéresse peu.
Je suis médecin,
j'ai un rapport avec les patients.
L'inquiétude que j'ai
dans l'idée d'une évolution
législative sur la fin de vie,
elle se ramène sur un principe,
un risque,
qui est le risque normatif.
Le risque de considérer que si,
dans une situation donnée,
la majorité des gens
choisissent ça,
alors cet homme ou cette femme
dont la situation, l'histoire,
fait qu'à un moment donné,
confronté
à cette situation de fragilité,
il s'engage dans un chemin
ou dans l'autre,
qu'il puisse y avoir
une influence
sur ce pouvoir d'autonomie
du sujet
guidée par des principes
normatifs.
Une société qui lui dit :
"Dans 95 % des cas,
"les gens dans votre état font ça."
C'est le seul élément.
Pour la question
dont vous parliez,
sur ce principe,
ça rebondit sur le lien
que nous avons avec nous-mêmes.
C'est bien prendre conscience
du fait
que je suis en discontinuité
avec le reste du monde,
mais aussi avec celui que j'ai été
dans le temps.
A chaque instant,
je suis un singleton,
ces ensembles à un seul élément,
qui, du haut de ma subjectivité
ici et maintenant,
pense quelque chose.
On est à chaque fois là-dedans.
C'est très important,
mais pour autant,
il faut garder à l'esprit
cette discrétion de nous avec nous.
Il est pas nécessaire
que je reste en accord avec celui
que je suis maintenant
au moment suivant
ou au moment précédent.
De là, j'en tire pas
un principe univoque,
mais juste cette lucidité
de se dire
que ce que je crois vouloir ici
s'applique ici
mais je décide de l'appliquer
à celui que je serai,
il y a une violence de soi à soi.
Parfois, il faut être
violent, sans doute,
mais simplement,
il faut le savoir.
Dans la vie, il m'est arrivé,
comme à beaucoup de collègues,
ou dans la vie de tout le monde,
de voir tous les cas de figure.
J'ai vu quelqu'un qui
s'était arrangé
pour vraiment pouvoir,
en conscience,
mettre fin à ses jours s'il était
en perte d'autonomie importante,
et qui, une fois qu'il arrive
dans cette situation,
veut vivre.
Et vous voyez l'inverse,
c'est pas...
-La continuité à soi-même
est aussi
une production permanente.
-Exactement,
et là, les neurosciences
contemporaines
et cette activité de clinicien
est une fenêtre
mais on en a beaucoup d'autres.
J'aime bien citer
des exemples littéraires.
Un de ceux qui m'a le plus
marqué,
c'est dans "La recherche",
de Proust,
le volume où Albertine s'en va,
il y a ce petit passage
où le narrateur réalise
qu'il est habité
par une multiplicité de lui-même.
A chaque instant,
le moment où il s'assoit,
le moment où il met ses pieds
dans des chaussons,
quand il va chez le coiffeur,
il vit l'expérience
qu'à chaque fois,
ce moi qu'il est
à ce moment-là
apprend comme pour la première fois
le départ d'Albertine.
Nous sommes habités
par une multiplicité
d'individus qui semblent être
en discontinuité.
J'ai cité ce passage,
il y en a beaucoup d'autres.
On peut donner une incarnation,
aujourd'hui, à cette idée.
-La question de la métaphore
pour passer d'un point de vue
à un autre,
passer de votre spécialité,
les pathologies neurologiques,
à un état des lieux du collectif.
Prenons une pathologie
sur laquelle vous auriez travaillé,
que ce soit...
C'est souvent des pathologies
discontinuistes,
la schizophrénie...
-Il y a en fait
deux points de départ
fondamentaux.
Quand vous faites de la neurologie,
la neurologie de la pensée,
des émotions,
des comportements,
ce qu'on appelle
la neuropsychologie,
cette dimension-là,
notre discipline,
qui a à peu près 250 ans,
est marquée par le principe
de dissociation.
Derrière l'unicité
et la continuité apparente
d'une fonction mentale,
le langage, la mémoire,
la conscience,
en fait, les troubles
de ces fonctions,
provoqués par des lésions
du cerveau,
vont nous révéler
chez les malades
une discontinuité,
une multiplicité
une sorte de mécano de choses qui,
lorsqu'elles sont dissociées,
on voit qu'elles sont différentes,
mais lorsque tout va bien,
on ne le voit pas.
Mais elles continuent
à rester différentes.
C'est la valeur ajoutée
de notre discipline.
Quand vous êtes neurologue
et psychiatre,
quand vous vous intéressez
aux pathologies,
vous vous intéressez aux patients
pour les aider,
comme le reste de la médecine,
et en plus,
il s'avère qu'avec cet effet,
entre guillemets,
sans aspect péjoratif,
mais l'aspect caricaturant
que provoque
sur notre fonctionnement
ce révélateur,
on découvre des choses
qu'on n'aurait pas imaginé
ou bien plus difficilement.
Quand on découvre,
fin 19e, début 20e,
que des patients amnésiques,
qui ne peuvent plus fixer
un nouveau souvenir conscient,
la mémoire épisodique,
sont capables de mémoriser
inconsciemment
plein d'autres choses,
des souvenirs moteurs, olfactifs,
des apprentissages,
on découvre que derrière
la mémoire au singulier,
on a une multiplicité
de mémoires différentes.
Tout ça pour vous dire
que ce qui peut paraître
comme une obsession,
la discontinuité,
quand vous rentrez
dans la mécanique
de la pensée,
tout est discontinu.
La continuité est le fruit
d'une sorte d'unification
qui produit cette impression
de continuité du monde et de nous.
Mais le facteur premier est plutôt
à voir du côté
de la discontinuité.
La schizophrénie est un exemple.
Le premier symptôme est
la dissociation.
La schizophrénie,
c'est la dissociation de l'esprit.
Là, c'est justement,
d'une certaine manière,
on pourrait dire
une faillite
par la pathologie psychiatrique
d'assurer
chez le sujet cette continuité.
On a besoin pour exister,
pour faire sens à nous-mêmes,
d'avoir une notion
de continuité.
Parfois, on me dit
que mon livre s'appelle
"L'apologie de la discrétion"
mais...
Je ne mets pas la continuité
au placard.
-Sinon, on en reste
à une forme de pathologie
où on ne peut plus articuler
de forme de mémoire.
-Exactement.
Dans une version éthique,
et je le développe,
je pense que ce principe radical
de la discrétion
est une forme d'égoïsme radical.
Ca n'a rien de péjoratif,
c'est descriptif.
Si on s'engage
sur une discrétion radicale,
on est déjà égoïste
avec nous-mêmes
donc on ne peut être qu'égoïste
avec les autres.
C'est une éthique
ou une morale, comme on veut,
mais c'est descriptif.
Apologie de la discrétion,
mais derrière, il y a cette tension.
En permanence, on a besoin
du discontinu et du continu.
L'acte de naissance
des neurosciences,
c'est un prix Nobel
en 1906,
quand un chercheur espagnol,
Ramon y Cajal,
découvre que les neurones,
que tout le monde connaît de nom,
les neurones,
au niveau de leur contact,
c'est son expression,
"entretiennent des relations
"de contiguïté
et pas de continuité".
C'est la naissance
de la discrétion.
Il a eu le prix Nobel pour ça.
La même année,
le deuxième prix Nobel,
Camillo Golgi,
un immense chercheur,
mais qui pensait
que le cerveau était continu.
Il a eu le prix Nobel
car il a inventé la technique
que Cajal a utilisé
pour contredire...
-Pour démontrer l'inverse.
-Il y a un côté
émission de Jacques Martin,
où tout le monde a 20 à la fin.
Les deux ont le prix Nobel
mais...
-Ca raconte bien la tension
entre les principes
qui continue de structurer...
-Il y a un aspect analogique
ou métaphorique dans lequel on est,
projeter ces questions
sur les débats contemporains.
Par exemple, là aussi,
je prends des exemples
de mouvements de lutte
contre des discriminations
ethniques, religieuses.
La lutte
contre les discriminations...
Il faut lutter
contre les discriminations.
Maintenant,
c'est les moyens de la lutte.
Et je pense que chaque fois
que cette lutte va pouvoir justifier
le fait de déplacer le curseur
au-delà de cet élément individuel,
discret,
en discontinuité, là,
ça pose problème.
Le fait d'imaginer
qu'on puisse interdire
ou censurer,
je prends cet exemple
qui existe,
qu'une poétesse néerlandaise,
homosexuelle, blanche,
traduise une poétesse
américaine noire,
qu'on dise non, pour moi,
c'est un problème.
C'est un problème
au sens où faire ça,
c'est empêcher
cette décision discrète de dire
que qui que je sois,
quelle que soit mon identité,
si je décide d'incarner
ou de m'associer à telle lutte,
je dois pouvoir le faire.
Inversement,
le deuxième effet pervers,
c'est d'imaginer...
Je prends l'exemple
d'Amanda Gorman
qui a écrit ce poème
à l'époque d'Obama,
l'idée qu'il faudrait
que la traductrice de ce poème
partage des critères collectifs
qui associent la poétesse
à ses traducteurs,
ça donne implicitement
l'idée
que les femmes hétérosexuelles
noires
sont dans une continuité,
ce qui est absurde.
Une fois de plus,
ce curseur,
c'est de dire
que pour toutes ces luttes-là,
je pense qu'il faut
mettre en avant
que le premier niveau
de valeur indépassable,
c'est l'individu conscient.
A partir de là, on fait
des "comme si" de continuité
avec différents principes.
C'est cette éthique.
-L'individu comme déclinaison
de possibilité
d'un collectif
et non pas
pour l'individualisme.
Le libéralisme est une forme
de continuisme.
-Exactement.
Un des points
qui a été moteur pour moi,
c'est que notre fils aîné,
quand j'étais depuis 2 ans
dans cette aventure,
m'a dit : "Est-ce que tu as lu
la thèse de Marx",
la thèse du jeune Marx,
qui était sur l'atomisme
de Démocrite et Epicure,
un texte assez court.
C'était pour moi une révélation
de se dire que la discrétion...
Parce que les atomes,
c'est ça.
Est-ce que la matière,
c'est des atomes ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des entités
discrètes fondamentales ?
Cette résonance n'est pas
que sur la matière
mais sur les individus.
De voir que cette paire de lunettes
discret-continu,
je n'étais pas le premier
à l'utiliser pour penser le lien
entre individu et collectif...
-Marx l'avait fait avant vous.
-Oui, Marx l'avait fait.
Donc voilà, c'est ça,
sur les épaules d'un géant.
Ca veut dire aussi
que cette question-là,
lorsqu'on commence à jouer
avec elle,
elle est fascinante
car complexe.
Vous vous en emparez,
les gens vous diront
que l'important, c'est l'individu,
que vous soyez de gauche
de droite.
La plupart des discours
vont perdre en route
cet aspect-là.
Pour des raisons de...
Le but ultime
d'une lutte politique.
Vous le disiez,
dans le libéralisme,
dans... Mais aussi
dans des pensées d'extrême gauche,
il y a parfois un point commun,
une méta invariance
où parfois,
vous perdez le sujet.
Ce n'est plus l'individu qui compte,
c'est l'humanité.
Mais elle ne peut exister
que s'il y a une collection
de sujets.
Ce n'est pas
parce que nous sommes séparés
que nous ne faisons pas
ensemble.
Il existe des ensembles discrets.
-La possibilité d'être ensemble,
c'est d'être séparé.
Merci beaucoup.
-Merci beaucoup.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA